m
[Musique]
bonjour à vis de vous retrouver pour ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture tout de
suite le sommaire la toile de jouy
source d'inspiration pour la mode d'hier
et d'aujourd'hui une cinquantaine de
pièces sont à découvrir jusqu'au 23
février au musée de jouy en josas
à travers l'exposition les toffes de ma
garde-robe
après le succès de génération lully le
centre de musique baroque de versailles
vient de lancer son nouveau projet
intergénérationnel et interculturel la
fontaine en scène va associer pendant
deux ans le cmbv ainsi que les villes de
trappes et de la verrière jusqu'en
décembre le public peut
exceptionnellement découvrir le poids
tueur à cordes de l'armée de terre à
travers une série de concerts focus sur
cette formation unique en son genre
basée dans les yvelines à satory des
costumes du xviiie siècle jusqu'aux
dernières robes aperçu dans les défilés
de haute couture le musée de la toile de
jouy à jouy en josas propos jusqu'au 23
février une exposition intitulée les
corps de ma garde-robe reportage mieux
faire connaître du grand public les
applications qu'ils étaient faits au
tissu des manufactures de jouy en josas
c'est toute l'ambition de cette nouvelle
exposition près acquisition aux
collections du musée une cinquantaine de
pièces ont été sélectionnées
on n'a jamais abordé d'aussi près le
thème du motif voilà le motif le dessin
tu es un thème très cher à oberkampf il
a toujours fait travailler de très
grands dessinateurs
il était très soucieux de la qualité des
dessins qui sortait de ses manies faible
sa manufacture et
on ne sent n'a jamais été abordée sous
cet angle là il s'agit essentiellement
de costumes du xviiie et du 19e siècle
des corps provenant des indes fleurs
motifs géométriques
chaque thématique est ponctuée d'une
création contemporaine pour montrer
comment ces motifs ont été réinterprétés
l'exposition se termine par un podium
dédié à la haute couture
là vous avez une pièce de castelbajac
alors là c'est vraiment il a utilisé un
motif de la toile de jouy qui est un
motif qui est qu'on retrouve dans nos
dans nos archives et il l'a totalement
modernisé
en faisant des allusions au rock ac dc
j'ai soif de futurs enfin c'est
totalement ses traits à la fois très
humoristique et est tout à fait dans nos
codes qu'en parallèle de cette
rétrospective des conférences des
visites guidées et des ateliers sont
proposés au public jusqu'en février 2020
[Musique]
après génération lully le cmb le centre
de musique baroque de versailles a lancé
le 17 octobre dernier son nouveau projet
la fontaine en scène un projet d'une
durée de deux ans auquel les villes de
trappes et de la verrière sont associés
ce projet intergénérationnel et
interculturel a pour objectif notamment
de faire découvrir et interpréter aux
habitants des villes
l'univers de jean de la fontaine dont on
fêtera d'ailleurs le 400e anniversaire
de la naissance en 2021
on a choisi la fontaine qui n'est pas un
musicien
parce que
ça me semblait très intéressant de
travailler le texte
la musicalité du pot du de la poésie on
sait que la langue française la musique
française c'est le chant français c'est
d'abord un travail sur le sur le parler
sur le texte sur la clarté sur la clarté
et la déclamation
c'est une un thème un sujet qui se prête
à des multiples interprétations et
réinterprétation puisque inde est un des
axes aussi du projet c'est de réécrire
des fable contemporaine avec notre
langage aujourd'hui nos préoccupations
d'aujourd'hui
sachant que l'homme reste l'homme à
travers les siècles et il est toujours
le même mais la forme les formes changer
peuvent se nourrir les unes des autres
à noter que l'exposition que vous avez
vu dans ces images est visible jusqu'au
1er novembre c'est à l'espace à chaque
nickel à la verrière le tremplin des
veaux à magny les hameaux se déroulera
le 1er février prochain ce sera la
cinquième saison a par ailleurs une
partie des auditions de présélection se
déroulera samedi 16 novembre ce sera de
10 heures à 17 heures à l'esplanade
gérard philipe et attention vous avez
jusqu'au 28 octobre pour vous inscrire
sur le site qui s'affiche sur votre
écran
je vous propose à présent de découvrir
une formation musicale unique en son
genre il s'agit du quatuor à cordes de
l'armée de terre les musiciens qui le
composent sont tous des militaires ils
sont basés dans les yvelines à satory à
nous les avons rencontrés à l'occasion
d'une série de concerts qu'il donne
actuellement les cancers qui sont
d'ailleurs ouverts au grand public
[Musique]
ils sont violonistes violoncellistes
altiste deux femmes deux hommes qui
forment le quatuor à cordes de l'armée
de terre basé à satory cette formation
est unique en son genre car elle est la
seule au sein de l'armée les musiciens
sont des militaires ils ont tous été
recrutés par concours a moi la musique
c'est depuis tout petit j'ai des parents
qui sont musiciens voilà j'ai fait des
études d'écriture aussi j'ai étudié en
allemagne je fais des arrangements pour
le quatuor aussi en fait j'ignorais
complètement qu'il y avait des missions
l'armée de terre je savais que la garde
la garde républicaine existait et donc
en fait je savais pas qu'on pouvait à la
fois tenir une arme et un violon dans
les mains
[Musique]
ce quatuor à cordes fait partie du
commandement des musiques de l'armée de
terre habituellement il se produit pour
les plus hautes autorités civiles et
militaires mais pour mieux les faire
connaître à certaines représentations
sont ouvertes au public une première
le but de cette série de concerts
c'était les faire découvrir
déjà d'une à la population versaillaise
parce que je pense que les versailles et
ne savent pas qu'il y ait un quatuor
dans leur ville de leur montrer aussi
que ban aux musiciens militaires peuvent
jouer bien évidemment du répertoire
classique le quatuor américain de jack
mais d'ubs et of due à une en fait ils
peuvent ils peuvent tous jouer
après la musique américaine les
prochains moments musicaux du quatuor à
cordes seront consacrés aux musiques
d'halloween ou encore de noël
quarante minutes de concert qui demande
une préparation quotidienne
nous devons être présents à la caserne
de 8h à 17h ton commence à répéter tous
ensemble vers 10h à peu près voilà et
ensuite l'après midi on alterne entre
travail personnel et répétitions à 4 en
fonction du programme qu'on a à monter
des concerts qu'on a à faire
l'auditorium peut accueillir jusqu'à 80
personnes pour découvrir le quatuor à
cordes de l'armée terre il suffit de
s'inscrire prochain rendez vous les 7 et
27 novembre
et si vous profitiez et des vacances
pour découvrir ou redécouvrir le
spectacle la voie de l'écuyer proposé
par l'académie équestre national de
versailles
ce spectacle chorégraphié par bartabas
alterne entre expression scénique et
techniques de dressage plusieurs
représentations sont proposés à partir
du 23 octobre et jusqu'au 29 décembre
[Musique]
et
love
du
m
réaliser un court métrage avec son
smartphone c'est ce que vous propose
l'association manic oise le cinoche
l'atelier aura lieu en avril prochain
sera composé de dix séances à la fin
votre court métrage sera diffusé à la
maison de l'environnement
une initiative originale proposée par
cette toute jeune association qui
favorise l'accès au cinéma pour tous le
but c'est vraiment de donner une
première expérience créative mais aussi
une première expérience de diffusion de
leurs projets donc en face d'un public
plutôt neutre sais pas je montre mon
court métrage à mes parents ou amis des
membres de la famille même s'ils peuvent
être notre public
le but c'est vraiment de donner aux
participants vraiment leur toute
première expérience cinématographique
on va les accompagner dans l'écriture du
scénario en sachant qu'il ya un thème
chaque année cette année c'est le thème
de la paix et puis on va les accompagner
dans le montage avec un montage basique
pour former un court métrage d'une
dizaine de minutes à ces professionnels
et le tout sera diffusé à la maison
l'environnement le 25 avril à 19 heures
lors du festival des courts métrages sur
smartphone après les courts métrages
place ou long métrage avec une soirée
sont bi lundi à 28 octobre à l'ugc
ciné-cité skywest à montigny le
bretonneux projection de deux films
alors tout d'abord à 20h bienvenue à
zombieland
puis avant 2 heures ce sera un retour à
zombieland c'est d'ailleurs une
avant-première petit extrait
pouvoir ouais je me suis tout petit il
est plus là il est les plus laids
je vois celui-là cette fille est
adorable
ma soeur a disparu
elle est partie avec un mec un gars de
berkeley dit serait pas de l'herbe sur
toi parce que j'ai la tête d'un mec qui
aurait de l'herbe je suis vraiment
désolé surprise si vous êtes allé à
trappes vous l'avez peut-être aperçu la
ville a accueilli une nouvelle sculpture
en rue maryse bastié
elle a été réalisée par l'artiste
nicolas scène manon varaldo était
présente lors de son installation ce
rond point que tout le monde appelle la
place au val a désormais une identité
nicolas sagne a réalisé une sculpture
d'une tonne 7
elle est installée rue maryse bastié ce
sont les trois linda c'est qu'ils sont
mariés entre elles normalement elles
sont blanches il nous faudra lever la
lamal âge elles seront blanches c'est
une sculpture qui parle d' espace ma
sculpture ce genre de ce style
d'assemblage on va dire de ligne 2 qui
frappe 21 15 éléments c'est selon c'est
le bon travail c'est ma marque de
fabrique
originaire de rodez nicolas sagna fait
le choix il y a un nom d'habiter trappe
suite à une demande du conseil municipal
de la ville l'artiste a conçu cette
pièce en quatre mois avec les
contraintes liées à l'aménagement urbain
si on arrive à sculpture l'ascum ouvert
en réalité à m cela parce qu'à côté
réseau des réseaux électriques des
réseaux de gaz des réseaux seul espace
urbain l'aménagement urbain les belles
de la ville qui passe de sous cette
place est à la jonction du quartier dit
de l'aéro stats et de celui des
merisiers l'endroit retenu pour
commémorer la mémoire d'arnaud beltrame
officier supérieur de la gendarmerie qui
s'était volontairement substituer à une
otage au cours de l' attaque terroriste
de mars 2018
à trèbes nous voulions rendre
hommage à monsieur beltrame pour l'acte
près presque surhumain qu'il a accompli
finalement de se laisser assassiner à la
place dans une personne qui n'avait pas
les fonctions des responsabilités qu'il
assume et on pouvait pas laisser passer
ça sans en marquer le souvenir
l'oeuvre de nicolas sanhes mesure 2
mètres 50 par trois mètres l'artiste est
ravie d'animer ce rond point rue maryse
bastié au printemps jeudi brinster
robert lee la date de naissance et si je
les vends et sculptures mal de coeur sur
la même année donc c'est une très belle
année
je suis ravi qu avec mon travail soit
accepté prochainement des bulbes rouge
de tulipes vont être plantés autour de
la sculpture patrimoine à d'intérêt
régional c'est le nom à du label décerné
par la région ile-de-france pour 87
sites
trois ont été retenus à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines des oeuvres
réalisées dans les années 1980 et 1990
est destiné à promouvoir l'art dans la
ville il s'agit de la perspective de
marta pan de meta un disque de granit de
nissim mercado le troisième il s'agit de
la porte de paris une arche métallique
de piotr kowalski
juste à côté le vélodrome nationale ce
label va notamment permettre à 50 et en
yvelines d'avoir accès à des aides pour
de la restauration ds aménagements voilà
c'est la fin de ce set 8 culture merci
de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve bien sûr
mardi prochain pour de nouveaux rendez
vous culturel
[Musique]